the site allocations plan is a list of
predominantly housing sites that would
come forward if we were unable to
deliver a five-year housing land supply
as required by the core strategy we're
not in that position we have a really
strong five-year housing land supply and
that's evidenced by the fact that within
the last three months a developer
brought forward an appeal based on
challenging a five-year housing land
supply when they saw our numbers they
abandoned the appeal so that's a really
strong place to start with secondly we
have a set of allocated sites already in
the core strategy which were on track
for delivery and as long as those sites
are delivered there is no need for us to
consider any of the reserve sites the
third area where sites could come
forward would be into what's called a
duty to cooperate in short if Birmingham
and Coventry can't demonstrate they've
got sufficient land to meet their needs
as a neighboring Authority we have to
help out the good news is we'd already
factored in a number of houses and have
delivered a number of houses to meet
that anticipated need so we're a really
long way from ever having to be in that
position and if anybody tried to bring a
site forward they would have to
demonstrate that firstly Birmingham or
Coventry had asked for and requested us
to cooperate and that there was no other
mechanism to deliver those houses within
the core strategy as it currently stands
so the bar is set really high in terms
of bringing any of those sites on stream
site allocations plan identifies a 20%
buffer which is circa 3,000 homes as I
said earlier on this is a reserve list
the bar is set extremely high and
there's a mechanism to ensure that when
people try to bring these sites forward
they have to hit certain checkmarks
around the five year land supply duty to
cooperate and we are nowhere near that
so I am absolutely confident there are
nearly five hundred homes in my own Ward
in biddeford identified in this plan and
I'm completely satisfied that the sites
are very unlikely ever to come forward
within this core strategy period I'd
like to send a message out to land
owners to property developers and also
to our local communities this reserve
listings exactly what it says it's a
reserve list
there is no need for us to bring these
sights forward as long as we deliver the
sights that are already allocated so if
you're a landowner if you're a developer
don't waste your time don't waste your
money and don't waste the effort of this
councils officers in bringing sites
forward which have no prospect
whatsoever of coming forward as
development sites within the core
strategy period up to twenty thirty one
I would also add that we are obliged to
undertake a review the core strategy
which will happen in 2020 that core
strategy review will undoubtedly look to
change the shape of future development
and will ultimately lead post 2031 to a
new core strategy so although we have to
go through this exercise this set of
sites could well be redundant early into
next year